how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and there
really is nothing quite like the marvel
cinematic universe a universe that
connects over 20 different movies and
stories and well
over 40 main characters bringing all of
those characters together in a perfect
way for avengers infinity war and
avengers end game
no interconnected universe has really
been done as well as the marvel
cinematic universe and in fact before
avengers end game took place and now
even after
fans have been re-watching the marvel
cinematic universe and what is now known
as the infinity saga
every mcu movie from the first iron man
to spider-man far from home and are
still loving
every single minute but even though the
mcu itself is amazing and the movies are
amazing as well there's still been one
big question asked by the fans for some
time now and that is
what is the order to watch every single
mcu movie in
well as it turns out marvel and disney
have finally come out and given us an
answer so for those of you who want the
official mcu
watch order this is the video for you
and be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a loki
funko pop
so this is coming straight from disney
plus and the order is not exactly what
you would expect it to be
but the first movie that we started off
with is captain america
the first avenger captain america the
first avenger takes place mainly in 1942
so it would make sense that it would be
the first movie that you watched and
then captain is followed by
another captain captain marvel whose
movie primarily takes place in the 90s
so again no surprise there that she
would be the second film to watch
and then the next two movies in order
are iron man 1
and iron man 2. they actually didn't
include the incredible hulk in this list
although his story does
kind of affect the mcu but of course
ultimately we would end up getting a new
hulk with the avengers played by mark
ruffalo so perhaps they wanted to take
that movie out of the mcu altogether or
perhaps it's a rates deal with universal
not allowing for marvel and disney to
officially put it on their list
but then we have thor which makes sense
because we have captain america iron man
and then came thor after thor comes the
avengers where all the main
first characters that were introduced
iron man captain america
black widow hawkeye and the hulk come
together in one epic
movie after the avengers comes thor the
dark
world after thor comes iron man 3 which
makes sense because in iron man 3
tony stark is dealing with the ptsd of
what happened from the first avengers
film
after iron man 3 we have captain america
the winter soldier
and then we have something kind of
interesting happen the next film to
watch
is guardians of the galaxy but the film
after that to watch
is guardians of the galaxy vol 2. it's
interesting that they have you watch
guardians vol 2 right after guardians 1
but before
avengers age of ultron because release
date wise guardians of the galaxy vol 2
didn't come out until after captain
america civil war and after doctor
strange
but in this official list we have
guardians vol 1 guardians vol 2 and then
avengers age of ultron coming up next
after avengers age of ultron
is ant-man and immediately following
ant-man is captain america
civil war following civil war we have
another little bit of a mix-up here
after civil war
is black panther then after black
panther we have doctor strange and then
thor ragnarok now this is a little
interesting because release date wise we
had doctor strange
then thor ragnarok then black panther
but who am i to argue with the official
order
so we have black panther doctor strange
thor ragnarok and then
ant-man and the wasp and that makes
perfect sense because the post-credits
scene for ant-man and the wasp is
directly
in avengers infinity war and that of
course takes us to avengers infinity war
and avengers end game and that is the
new official
mcu watch order from disney plus and
marvel
now one thing to note here is that
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home are not included in this list
and the reason i'm assuming these two
spider-man films are not on this list is
because this list
is coming from disney plus and disney
plus does not yet have spider-man
homecoming and spider-man far from home
on their platform yet but of course we
know where they would go in the mcu
you can watch spider-man homecoming
after the events of captain america
civil war
and of course spider-man far from home
is the last movie of phase 3 watched
right after avengers in game so this is
the new
official watch order for the mcu and it
seems to be primarily chronological
which makes a ton of sense and i'm
personally really excited to watch it in
this order
so let me know what you think about this
order and let me know in the comments
down below if you yourself are going to
be watching it in this order as well
don't forget to give the video a like
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof